BRIAN: ALL RIGHT.
TAKING A LITTLE BREAK.
MEANWHILE LET’S BRING IN SARAH
SANDERS FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR,
FORMER WHITE HOUSE SECRETARY,
SARAH, WELCOME BACK.
>> THANK YOU, GREAT TO BE WITH
YOU GUYS THIS MORNING.
BRIAN: THE PRESIDENT LAYED OUT A
FRAMEWORK ON THURSDAY AND HE
SAID THIS IS WHAT YOU NEED TO DO
TO GET THROUGH PHASE 1, 2 AND 3
AND LAW IT BIT LATER HE TWEETED
OUT SUPPORT FOR THOSE
PROTESTING.
DO YOU BELIEVE HE CAN DO BOTH
LAY OUT A FRAMEWORK AND SUPPORT
PROTESTORS AND USE TERM
LIBERATE?
>> LOOK, THERE’S NOBODY THAT
WANTS TO REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT
MORE THAN PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE WANTS TO SEE PEOPLE GETTING
BACK TO WORK.
HE’S A BUSINESSMAN AT HEART AND
HE WANTS BUSINESSES IN THIS
COUNTRY TO BE ABLE TO OPEN, TO
BE ABLE TO THRIVE, AT THE SAME
TIME HE’S MAINTAINED SOCIAL
DISTANCING GUIDELINES AND PEOPLE
NEED TO TAKE THEM SERIOUSLY AND
AT THE END OF THE DAY MILLIONS
OF AMERICANS ARE FRUSTRATED,
THEY ARE WATCHING LIBERAL
POLITICIANS LIKE NANCY PELOSI GO
ON TV AND -- AND ON SOCIAL MEDIA
PARADING AROUND FLASHING THEIR
13-DOLLAR POINT ICE CREAM IN
THEIR FACES WHEN THEY DON’T HAVE
$13 TO FEED THEIR FAMILIES.
THERE’S NO DOUBT THAT THEY ARE
FRUSTRATED AS A LOT OF THE
PEOPLE THAT DEPEND ON SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE ANGRY THAT THEY
ARE NOT OPENING BACK UP AND THAT
THEIR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
DELAYING MORE FUNDING THAT WE
ARE SEEING FROM PELOSI AND THE
DEMOCRATS JUST OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF WEEKS AND AS WE SAW
KEVIN MCCARTHY TALKING ABOUT
EARLIER, PEOPLE ARE GETTING
ANGRY, THEY ARE GETTING UPSET
AND THEY WANT PEOPLE OUT OF
TOUCH POLITICIANS LIKE NANCY
PELOSI TO START PAYING ATTENTION
TO THE REAL NEEDS THAT THEY HAVE
AND HELPING THEM STEP UP AND
MEET THOSE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, CONGRESS
GETS PAID WHETHER THEY SHOW UP
TO WORK OR NOT AND THEY DON’T
UNDERSTAND SOMETIMES THAT PEOPLE
THAT HAVE TO SHOW UP IN ORDER TO
GET A PAYCHECK AND CAN’T ARE
FRUSTRATEED.
AINSLEY: SOME OF THE PROTESTORS
ARE ANGRY, THE ONES SHOWING UP
TO PROTEST, THEY DON’T WANT TO
STAY AT HOME AS LONG AS THEY ARE
FOLLOWING THE RULES.
WE SAW PROTESTS.
WE WILL SEE TEN ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TODAY AND SOME OF THEM
ARE HOLDING UP SIGNS THAT SAY
END THE VIRUS, NOT THE ECONOMY.
READ ONE THAT SAYS EVERY DAY
THAT GOES BY YOU’RE HURTING OUR
STATE AND ANOTHER GUY SAID --
THE SHUTDOWN AND ECONOMIC COST
NOT WORTH THE FEW LIVES THAT IT
WILL SAVE.
SO NANCY PELOSI WAS ASKED ABOUT
IT AND THIS IS WHAT SHE SAID.
CHRIS: CAN YOU UNDERSTAND WHY
THEY ARE DOING THAT?
>> NO, NOT REALLY, BECAUSE WHAT
WE HAVE TO DO IS -- IS SHELTER
IN PLACE.
THAT IS REALLY THE ANSWER,
TESTING, TRACING, TREATMENT,
SHELTER IN PLACE AND I DO THINK
THAT IT’S UNFORTUNATE.
BUT YOU KNOW, PEOPLE WILL DO
WHAT THEY DO, BUT THE FACT THAT
WE ARE ALL IMPACTER AND WE ALL
WANT OUT BUT WHAT THEY ARE DOING
IS REALLY UNFORTUNATE.
AINSLEY: SARAH, WHAT’S YOUR
REACTION?
>> FRANKLY, I THINK WHAT’S
UNFORTUNATE IS THAT AN OUT OF
TOUCH MULTIMILLIONAIRE LIKE
NANCY PELOSI IS HOLDING UP THE
FUNDING THAT WOULD HELP THESE
PEOPLE NOT JUST SAVE LIVES BUT
SAVE LIVELIHOODS.
THIS IS HAS BEEN INTENT FOCUS OF
THE PRESIDENT PROTECTING BOTH
PART OF THE AMERICAN WAY OF
LIFE, BOTH PROTECTING INDIVIDUAL
HEALTH AND LIFE OF AMERICANS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AS WELL AS
MAKING SURE WE ARE PROTECTING
THEIR LIVELIHOODS AND NANCY
PELOSI, YOU CAN SEE THAT SHE
FRANKLY DOESN’T UNDERSTAND THE
FRUSTRATION OF PEOPLE WHO NEED
THEIR JOBS OR NEED FUNDING
THROUGH THE SMALL BUSINESS
PACKAGE AND LEGISLATION IN ORDER
TO GET THEIR PAYCHECKS AND KEEP
THINGS MOVING.
SHE JUST FRANKLY SHOWED EXACTLY
WHY SHE IS SO OUT OF TOUCH AND I
THINK THAT’S THE MOST
UNFORTUNATE THING ABOUT IT IS
THAT SHE’S ONE OF THE PEOPLE
MAKING DECISIONS FOR EVERYBODY
ELSE IN THIS COUNTRY BUT SHE
DOESN’T UNDERSTAND THE PAIN AND
THE HURT AND THE SUFFERING THAT
THESE PEOPLE ARE GOING THROUGH
BECAUSE SHE’S NOT HAVING TO
SUFFER OR EXPERIENCE ANY OF THAT
HERSELF BECAUSE SHE HAS THE
CUSHION AND THAT FINANCIAL
SECURITY THAT MOST AMERICANS
DON’T HAVE.
STEVE: YOU KNOW, SARAH, I THINK
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN WATCHING
THIS RIGHT NOW, THEY ARE WORRIED
ABOUT THEIR HEALTH, THEY ARE
WORRIED ABOUT THEIR WEALTH.
THEY WONDER WHEN THIS ENDS AND
WHEN THEY SEE PEOPLE WHO ARE
PLAYING POLITICS WITH THIS
DURING THE TIME OF A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC, WHETHER IT’S A
REPUBLICAN OR A DEMOCRAT, I’VE
SEEN IT PLAY ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE, THE PERSON AT HOME
JUST GOES, CAN’T WE GET THIS
SOLVED FIRST BECAUSE IT’S JUST
-- IT JUST SEEMS TONE DEAF.
>> SARAH: I DON’T THINK THERE’S
PROBABLY ANYTHING MORE
DISHEARTENING THAN SEEING
WASHINGTON BEING COMPLETELY
DYSFUNCTIONAL AT A TIME WHEN WE
NEED IT TO COME TOGETHER MORE
THAN EVER TO HELP THE PEOPLE OF
THIS COUNTRY.
I THINK ONE OF THE GREAT THINGS
THAT HAS TAKEN PLACE OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL WEEKS IS WE’VE SEEN
THE HEART OF AMERICA.
WE’VE SEEN PEOPLE STEP UP AND
HELP THEIR NEIGHBORS.
WE’VE SEEN SO MANY SIGNS OF
PEOPLE SHOWING COMPASSION AND
LOVE IN A WAY THAT WE DON’T GET
TO ALWAYS APPRECIATE.
WE DON’T SLOW DOWN TO TAKE.
I THINK WASHINGTON NEEDS TO PAY
ATTENTION TO SOME OF THAT
COMPASSION AND SOME OF THAT LOVE
THAT EVERYDAY AMERICANS ARE
CONSTANTLY SHOWING AND TRY TO
REFLECT SOME OF THAT AND MOVE
QUICKLY TO GET THINGS DONE AND
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE HAVE THE
RESOURCES AND THE THINGS THAT
THEY NEED TO CONTINUE AND TO
CARRY ON WITH THEIR WAY OF LIFE.
THIS IS AMERICA.
WE STILL CONTINUE TO BE THE
GREATEST COUNTRY ON THE FACE OF
THE PLANET.
LET’S ACT LIKE IT AND LET’S GET
THINGS DONE AND LET’S MAKE SURE
WE ARE TAKING GOOD CARE OF
PEOPLE AND I THINK THE PRESIDENT
HAS BEEN A STRONG LEADER ON THAT
FRONT AND WE NEED TO RALLY
AROUND HIM, WE NEED TO RALLY
AROUND OUR GOVERNORS, DOCTORS
AND NURSES AND NOT POLITICIZE
THE FIGHT BUT REALLY FOCUS ON
THE SOLUTIONS INSTEAD OF THE
ATTACKS.
BRIAN: RIGHT, SARAH, NO MATTER
WHAT THEY AGREE ON ON WEDNESDAY
OR THURSDAY, IT COULD HAVE BEEN
DONE A WEEK TO TEN DAYS AGO.
THERE’S REALLY NO EXCUSE AND
ONLY ONE PERSON WHO DELAYED IT
AND SHE HAS REALLY NICE
REFRIGERATORS.
THAT’S ALL I CAN SAY.